in this capsule to have them
two star theoretical properties including
we are going to do we make the list of
different properties most
important of the star without making it the
demonstration
and you will see that most are
still quite intuitive
so first property two stars
is that if the graffiti is finished to star
is always finished and that's due
among other things, that weights
associated with transitions are strictly
positive and thanks among other thanks
also the clause list of it's
possible also to check if we are in
to explore some of the graffiti that
has already been explored before if there was
cycles in serious
then sacy a path to the goal
exist to star is going to find one
so actually since we explore
basically all the paths in
adding a draw when growing up final
finally graffiti as you go
by calling transition is good
eventually we will have covered all
the possible paths so if it exists
a goal a path to bio we go in
find there is a property that is
particularly important fundamental
with 1 star
sinnott heuristic h edel that the estimated
that it gives real future cost and a
always less than or equal to the actual cost
to come up
we will say that the rustic in question
is eligible and if we have this
property the man we can say that it is
an important result that hay canvas
always returns an optimal path
in fact when we look in the
star discussion of different
authors sometimes some assume that
or if we talk about the stars
logistics is needed manny sid so
for some the definition of stars
it's not just that fdn and
garages and additionally hd n but that in addition
hd n is eligible and so that's a
property particularly important if
we want to make sure we get
at the end of the roof, an optimal path
must make sure that our tourist is
admissible that is to say that it will
around an estimate that is lower or
equal to the real cost future of hand
until the end we can make links
enters into stars and looking for
money
so in fact using costs of
evenly equal arcs so h of forgiveness
so of 1 m prime which is equal for
all links between seniors a premium
for all the seniors in bonus is
strictly positive so for example
for blows there is there everywhere and
that energy that always returns
zero for all our hatreds then to star
actually corresponds to a search in
width so actually since in
this case fdn low corresponds to j2m is not
than j2m to match the length
of the way if we had costs equal to 1
and seeing that in open you bring out the
elements who acted out of hatred finally
the smallest one goes essentially
take out the knots that have a distance
with the shortest initial name and
so we did come to a search
in width and in this case we have
also that open will become one that
last in lace out or in french last
between he last released we can do
also reign with the al heal of size
3 sino tourist is such that she
always returns anonymously than me
also 0 so so logistic is such
that they always return zero but
that we still have variable costs to
star becomes equivalent to such a
small subtle on the other hand a small
difference to you will stop him
when we found our optimal path
green towards the goal because you have too much
it only needs to stop
we will continue in fact until we
found the optimal path green or
line height would stop him
really done in the three courses
they do not even find
finally this way lovers the
of and also notes that h of hate
legal 06 a logistics that is
admissible since actually the
way between reindeer and the goal will be
necessarily bigger magal did
strictly larger at zero unless a
enemy the iron menu brought some
definitions for the next
property to be defined so we will note f
hate stars the optimal path so
not an egg not an esteemed but really
the way up pardon the optimal path of the
initial name to the bus that go through
m unlike our f2 is our
evaluation function that normally
it is to estimate the cost of this path
optimal dance that if she does you
names will really refer to the
neck of the optimal path that goes from one
initial passing through reindeer is over
drank the same way I star from 1.9 to
match the optimal path of a
initial to node n is to chetouane
of hatred we will define it as the
exact cost of the optimal path that speaks
of a hate and that will be a goal honor
so with these definitions there we can
establish that f stars of hate it is
equal g canvas of n 10 h m stars so
actually the optimal nude during the
optimal path that starts from an initial
which goes through the n and ends in water
bath necessarily sarraute is the
cost of the new little marquis starts from a
united if way of the match by dunod
initial to the node ncg hand
plus the cost of the optimal path by so much
of hatred and going to the draw to ch
air stars and so makes it one of
Pippin 'star properties
logistics is admissible it is that
every node n explored by to stars on
can demonstrate that for each sign
we still have only the function
of calculated estimates f2 n is no longer
small or equal to effect canvas
so in fact we have not overestimated
never
the actual cost of the optimal path passing
by m
another interesting definition a
interesting property for
rustic is that of coherence
so if we have any 1 in 1 and a
successor n 2 and that for his dunes of
we are still only logistics
ah1n1 and smaller or equal to the cost of
go from n2 plus the rest to haendel on
will say at that moment that h and
consistent
so that's a definition we give ourselves
thoroughly we will go as far
some will say that will do and do
refer to investing it as being
monotonous and in reality cf that becomes
monotonous but good so 6h satisfied
this definition the hedge and consistent
really we can demonstrate that buys
also nbc so never overestimate the
remaining cost of the optimal hate path
towards the goal and besides and that's a
property that is even more
interesting
whenever the star choose our
beginnings of open so processes an output of
open then to the stars to find the
optimal path that will be at this draw is in
does the name so will never be visited in
the future in re canvas performance
so this is a property that is
particularly interesting because
in a way it's a guarantee
we will not do a job twice
visit in more than one time the same name
so having a consistent stick on
make sure that if we visit a place where we
will visit only once
another property if we have two
lawyers etc eligible h1 and h2 and that
they are such that h12 is still
smaller than 12 h of hate so at
shenzhen is always a
underestimation by contribution hd n
but that both are eligible then
we will see that h2 will drive more
quickly to the goal to explore or
exploit never more honor than h that
the risk so to stars that would use
the restic shopping also 6 pm is not
admissible but we have
of alleurs b who is going to be a good
surprise over overestimation
so in other words if we did not
that hdn we can guarantee that these more
little ugal that the ha hate stars
so the real cost of the optimal path for
from a n went to the goal more
uncertain some additional good
in this case also to star will return
a solution whose cost is at most
low
more than the optimal cost so to you
is not going to be wrong by more than 10 by
compared to optimality so that it can
to be interesting if we are not in
able to find eligible ristic but
we have for one reason or another the
ability to ensure that we do not overestimate
no more a certain barabé one can
translate that to guarantees on
optima it and the path that is going to be
returned by not being
returned by a roof and finally two
last property if we only have our
tourist is exactly station at
buy hate canvas for everything and am
the optimality of the star and guarantees
so actually if you do
often think a little
you will see when done every time
to star is going to take a place that
belongs to the optimal path since h
hate stars we
directly indicates what are the nerves
who have a cost the cost that is the most
down so following these knots there it's
what light is right one of rhdp ira
at you den we will go directly
towards their goal and then finally it's
maybe faster than properties
different but if we roll to stars
with a function is rustic that is
not eligible so we have that star
will find a solution if it exists
but we are not sure that she is
optimal hence hence the interest of watching
its properties of the canvas is between
others to know that if they managed to
define a style that is eligible or
even better that is consistent but
when if we only have the solution of
the star is well and truly
optima